you first no not you first the one aha
moment that I've taken away is that we
are dreadfully small and there's not a
really apparent reason why yet but
that's we're still trying to figure out
so we've asked for input from a couple
people they're doing some homework and
looking at our channel to try to figure
out it yeah we walked up Freddie Wong
like can you diagnose why we're not
making the viewership that we should you
took our car they said tweet me later
for free that and um that's where we're
at we that was his take away hi everyone
Oh every panel every panel we've walked
into I've listened to everything they
say and I just go down like a checklist
done that done that done that doing that
that's in progress and I'm like they're
all checked what am I missing here what
are not working for us that everybody
else seems to be you know hitting home
so I haven't figured it out yet I don't
know if it's just we think it's look we
think there is some level of it falls on
the right page at the right minute that
the right person happens to be on the
page who has influenced who says that
came up on your newsfeed today I'm going
to tweet that for you know 50,000 people
it's not to say that talents not
required because like this there's like
first you have to have a great video we
have to clear the bar then on top of
that you have to get that one lucky
moment because there are great leaders
all over the Internet I think we don't
know but yeah but that's see definitely
something I think I'm taking away is
you really just have to be somewhat in
the right place at the right time which
is the same as the rest of the industry
that you really there are opportunities
and you need to be available for
opportunities you need to be capable of
grabbing opportunities but outside of
that you have to keep trying to make
opportunities and that's you know all we
can do right now my takeaways we have to
collaborate my takeaway is there is
there are channels out there who have
probably similar numbers of subscribers
to us but they're totally different
human beings subscribe to them so if
we're similar to another channel you
need to work together and those
applicable subscriptions are going to
you know pop over to your channel
because you're doing the same stuff and
you're doing stuff that they love and so
if you work together you'll hopefully be
able to build a lot more a lot more
traffic just because you're working with
other people who have totally different
people on their channel so I don't know
that's the time
you